bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero
este 18 de marzo se cumplen 60 años de
los acuerdos debían un episodio clave en
la historia contemporánea francesa que
puso fin a una de las guerras coloniales
más sangrientas del siglo pasado la
guerra de independencia de argelia un
conflicto que enfrentó entre 1954 y 1962
a la metrópoli francesa y a la que por
más de un siglo fue su colonia más
importante
la presencia francesa en territorio
argelino se remonta a la década de 1830
durante años cientos de miles de colonos
europeos se instalaron en argelia para
ocupar y explotar tierras y el poder
francés fue penetrando desde las
ciudades costeras hasta el interior
desértico esta ocupación fue generando
una división social entre colonos
europeos y nativos musulmanes de la
región que desembocó en un profundo
descontento un contexto que propició el
surgimiento en la primera mitad del
siglo 20 de movimientos nacionalistas y
secesionistas de diferente índole que
progresivamente fueron reprimidos con
dureza por francia la segunda guerra
mundial hizo que estas aspiraciones
crecieran en dirección a la búsqueda de
una autodeterminación parcial o total
durante la década posterior al conflicto
mundial se produjeron episodios
esporádicos de violencia e intentos de
autodeterminación que fracasaron hasta
que en marzo de 1954 se funda el frente
de liberación nacional una coalición de
fuerzas independentistas que optó por la
lucha armada
guerra contra el estado francés para
obtener la independencia durante los
primeros meses apenas contó con una
estructura fuerte pero la represión
durísima de las autoridades francesas
hizo que su apoyo entre la población
aumentará francia había perdido otros
territorios de ultramar pero no estaba
dispuesta a perder a argelia su colonia
más importante
parís llegó a desplegar en territorio
argelino hasta 400 mil soldados y aunque
en un principio no tomó en serio el
peligro que representaba el fmln pronto
comprobó que se trataba de una amenaza
real
este grupo adoptó técnicas similares a
las de los independentistas en la
colonia francesa de indochina y masacres
como la de philip build en
1955 fueron un punto de inflexión que
llevaron al conflicto a la guerra total
debido a su crueldad en este episodio
docenas de colonos europeos fueron
asesinados por insurgentes del fmln de
esta forma el fmln consiguió poco a poco
implantarse territorialmente y decidió
llevar a cabo una campaña de ataque las
principales ciudades así en septiembre
de 1956 se inició la batalla de argel
uno de los episodios más sangrientos de
la contienda la capital fue asediada y
bombardeada durante meses y miles de
civiles murieron los franceses tuvieron
órdenes de responder con todo y se
reportaron casos de ejecuciones
extrajudiciales
métodos que atentaban contra los
derechos humanos represión torturas e
incluso la creación de campos de
concentración para la población argelina
medidas que escandalizaron a la opinión
internacional
el conflicto se convirtió en una guerra
de guerrillas y un enfrentamiento entre
diferentes facciones el fmln no
solamente luchaba contra la presencia
francesa sino también contra los
argelinos que estaban en contra de la
independencia los llamados harkis fueron
una pieza fundamental de la
contrainsurgencia francesa que llegó a
crear grupos paramilitares de bandera
falsa que operaban contra el fmln el
conflicto aceleró la caída de la cuarta
república francesa en 1958
el mariscal charles de gaulle quien se
mostró abierto hacia la independencia
argelina
linda
lista
los muertos los atentados han hecho que
esta población se haya dado cuenta desde
que dura que la actual sistema
instaurado en parís no puede solucionar
sus problemas ella brilla pan
de gaulle inició una serie de
conversaciones con los independentistas
para poner fin a la guerra algo que no
sentó especialmente bien entre los
descendientes de europeos que vivían en
argelia que para 1960 eran algo más de
un millón de gaulle organizó el primer
referendo sobre la independencia de
argelia en enero de 1961 y el resultado
fue afirmativo tanto en francia como en
argelia un contexto que facilitó las
conversaciones con el fnl en evian y la
posterior firma de un alto el fuego
permanente el 18 de marzo de 1962 además
se garantizaron una serie de plazos para
la conformación de argelia como estado
independiente en los siguientes meses
la conclusión
y la conclusión del alto el fuego en
argelia son las medidas adoptadas para
que las poblaciones allí tengan su
propio destino y después de la testa
la perspectiva y sur
la perspectiva que se abre del
advenimiento de un ángel independiente
que coopere estrechamente con nosotros
satisface la razón de francia
satisfará eso
el acuerdo puso fin a ocho años de una
sangrienta guerra que se cobró la vida
de 350.000 personas según el estado
francés y 15 millones según el frente de
liberación nacional pero también
ocasionó el éxodo casi total de todos
los argelinos de descendencia europea o
judía que ante el ascenso al poder del
fmln temieron por su futuro este
conflicto marcó durante las décadas
siguientes la relación entre francia y
argelia que nunca se pudo reponer por
completo de hecho la tensión diplomática
se mantiene hasta la actualidad con
episodios esporádicos de crisis con esto
concluimos gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]